Das war so verletzend, ich habe mich
gefühlt, wie der letzte Dreck.
Bist du noch da?
- Ja, hmmmhhh.
*Titelmelodie*
Herzlich willkommen zum
langersehnten 3. und letzten Teil
unserer Serie zur "Dunklen Triade".
Nach Narzismus und Marciavellismus
widmen wir uns heute
dem wohl berühmtesten Drittel
der "Dunklen Trirade,
nämlich der Psychopathie.
"Psychopath", da stellt man sich
Menschen vor wie Hannibal Lecter
oder allgemein kaltblütige
Mörder und Gewaltverbrecher.
Dabei ist Psychopathie viel
alltäglicher als die meisten meinen.
Ähnlich wie beim Narzismus
unterscheidet man bei Psychopathie
zwischen einer psychopathischen
Persönlichkeitsstörung,
die medizinisch diagnostiziert
werden kann und sogenannten
subklinischen Ausprägungen, die
angeblich jedem von uns innewohnen,
wenn auch in verschiedenen Ausmaßen.
Ein Kind, das mit Freude einen
Regemwurm zerquetscht, zeigt bereits
psychopathische Anzeichnen.
Innerhalb der "Dunklen Triade"
sind die Übergänge fließend,
v.a. in Kombination mit
Marciavellismus tritt Psychopathie
häufig auf.
Man könnte aber sagen, der größte
Unterschied zwischen Marciavellisten
und Psychopathen
ist die Impulsivität.
Während Marciavellisten eher kühl
abwägen, handeln Psychopathen oft
impulsiv oder agressiv, ohne sich
über die Konsequenzen ihres Handelns
Gedanken zu machen.
Die 1. Kernessenz von Psychopathie
ist ein Mangel an Empathie.
Empathie ist die Fähigkeit, sich in
andere Menschen hinein zu versetzen
und mit ihnen mitzufühlen.
(weint)
Forscher der Universität Groningen
untersuchten Häftlinge, bei denen
eine psychopathische Persönlich-
keitsstörung diagnostiziert wurde,
mit Hilfe von Magnetresonanz-
tomografie untersuchten sie
die Hirnaktivität der Probanden
während diese Videoclips schauten.
Die Viedeoclips zeigten Hände zweier
Menschen, die entweder neutrale,
liebevolle, schmerzvolle oder
ablehnende Berührungen zeigten,
d.h., normales Berühren, Streicheln,
Schlagen oder Wegstoßen.
Dabei stellte sich heraus, dass
die Hirnaktivität der Psychopathen
klar niedriger lag als die Kon-
trollgruppe von Nicht-Psychopathen.
Interessant ist aber,
dass Psychopathen grundsätzlich
nicht unfähig zur Empathie sind.
Als man den Probanden sagte,
sie sollen sich aktiv
in die anderen Menschen, also
in die 2 Hände, hineinversetzen,
konnte eine deutlich höhere
Gehirnaktivität gemessen werden.
Man könnte sagen, die Empathie
kann angeschaltet werden.
Neben einem Mangel an Empathie ist
die 2. charakteristische Eigenschaft
von Psychopathen eine besonders
ausgeprägte Furchtlosigkeit.
Psychopathen sind also nicht nur
impulsiv, sondern auch risikobereit
und haben eine erhöhte
Wahrscheinlichkeit an Dingen
wie Bungee Jumping Spaß zu haben.
Forscher der Uni Bonn
plädieren daher
für einen differenzierteren Blick
auf Psychopathie.
Ihren Beobachtungen zufolge,
sind Psychopathen
nicht zwingend anti-sozial.
Erfolgreiche Psychopathen können
sozial völlig unauffällig sein.
Es wird sogar diskutiert, ob die
Furchtlosigkeit von Psychopathen
sie zu besonders geeigneten
Lebensrettern wie Notärzten
oder Feuerwehrleuten machen könnte.
Diese Berufe setzen eine
gewisse Selbstlosigkeit voraus,
aber ein Mangel an Empathie ist
nicht gleichzusetzen mit Egoismus.
Zusammenfassend gesagt,
ein kaltblütiger Mörder
ist mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
ein Psychopath, aber ein Psychopath
muss noch lange kein kaltblütiger
Mörder sein, sondern vielleicht
auch ein selbtsloser Feuerwehrmann.
Schön schlau.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Wie der Rest der "Dunklen Triade"
steckt Psychopathie
in jedem von uns.
Wenn ihr wissen wollt, wie
viel Psychopathie in euch steckt,
in der Infobox ist wieder
der kleine Selbsttest, falls ihr
den noch nicht gesehn habt.
Ansonsten, Fragen oder
Themenvorschläge, schreibt sie
in die Kommentare.
Wir sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag,
bis dahin, bleibt sicher.